et pour en parler de ce conflit
commercial entre les états unis et
l'union européenne avec nous sur ce
plateau philippe bichard analyste
financier rédacteur en chef de la bourse
au quotidien bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors on parle de poulet au chlore
1 pour mieux comprendre il s'agit d'une
méthode de conditionnement utilisez donc
parler les américains à ce que donald
trump des pas là en train de
conditionner la reprise des négociations
commerciales
on les reprend seulement si vous
acceptez notre poule et au chlore et
notre boeuf aux hormones oui c'est l'art
du deal américain c'est-à-dire qu'on
négocie la matraque à la main
le boeuf aux hormones le poulet au
chlore les premiers confie à ce sujet ça
remonte au milieu des années 70 dire que
ça date pas d'hier
et à l'époque les américains se montrer
extrêmement protectionnistes également
vis-à-vis de produits européens que je
qualifierais de plus artisanaux par
exemple impossible d'exporter aux états
unis des des produits alimentaires qui
comptent porte enfin qu'ils ne sont pas
neutres bactériologiquement c'est à dire
que attendre les fromages les terrines
et enfin l état de chose que les
américains évidemment non mis des
barrières on va dire sanitaires
les aux hormones à un boeuf aux hormones
poulet au chlore
si jamais les américains a obtenu gain
de cause de toute façon sa forteresse
sur des quantités très faibles
je crois que l'europe importe plus de
viande d'ailleurs du canada des
états-unis et en ce qui concerne le
poulet américain par rapport aux poulets
surgelés brésilien il n'est pas
concurrentiel donc même si les européens
acceptaient le d'un point de vue
réglementaire d'apporter du poulet
américain toute façon ils seraient ils
feraient pas le poids par rapport au
plaisir
donc je pense que c'est et fit une fois
une nouvelle façon pour trump
d'extorquer aux européens plus de plus
de souplesse
mais c'est rien en comparaison de larmes
absolue dont disposent les américains
qui est l'extraterritorialité de leurs
droits et qui là s'applique dans tous
les conflits industrielle est excellent
on l'a vu avec l'iran on avait vu les
banques françaises se faire racketter
littéralement il ya quatre ans là aussi
sur le contournement des restrictions à
l'usagé du du dollar donc menacé
l'europe de plus de taxes sur
l'automobile pour pousser le le poulet
je dirais qu économiquement ça pas grand
sens mais ça en a un par contre ça parle
à son électorat économiquement l'enjeu
du poulet ou encore électorale alors
c'est bien sûr parce que le cc 06 30
taxes les automobiles européennes
c'est quoi c'est du haut de gamme c'est
des berlines allemandes qui consomment
ce genre de véhicule c'est la peur
classe américaine qui ne votent pas
tremblé de toute façon donc taxer les
automobiles airs apporté des deux
d'europe ça valait renchérir pour une
clientèle qui n'est pas son électorat
donc je crois que trump parle davantage
à son électorat
je pense que la négociation à ce niveau
là n'a pas grand sens
économie justement concrètement mon nez
ou non ces négociations commerciales
parce qu'elles doivent reprendre puisque
sûrs cela van der leyen doit bientôt
justement se rendre à washington est ce
qu'on peut espérer que les négociations
pourront prendre peut-être sereinement
entre les deux a sereinement
elles ont bien commencé puisque en fait
ursula von der woerd airlines
elle a été appelée au téléphone par 30
je crois que c'était une 19 janvier
juste avant qu'ils décollent à davos et
il l'a appelé pour lui dire je sors la
matraque et ça va être 25 % de taxe sur
les automobiles
si on trouve pas un arrangement donc
voilà elles sont bien partis les
négociations n'a naturellement leur
après ça y'a l'accusation de 30 qui dit
ouah les européens ne sont plus
compliquées plus dur que les chinois
c'est totalement faux c'est juste que
ursula von der leyen elle ne porte pas
la voix de l'ensemble de l'europe
il ya fort que les etats-unis négocient
avec chaque pays par exemple l'histoire
du du poulet au chlore peut-être que ça
passera en allemagne mais ça passera pas
en france en italie en espagne donc la
difficulté pour trame c'est pas trop con
on est durs en affaires on ne l'est pas
deuxièmement lui il à l'extracteur
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
dont comme nous ils nous enfoncent
complètement la seule chose c'est que là
c'est compliqué de négocier avec une
europe qui ne sortent de deux de
mosaïques ses tours c'est surtout ça
était un position de force actuellement
dans ces négociations les états unis
l'union européenne
alors je dirais que la trappe et
évidemment en situation de force sont
les etats unis sont le plus fort dans
tous les domaines dont il ya pas se
poser de question de savoir qui est le
plus fort maison que là nous on a peut
être un moyen de se défendre qui est
justement qu'il n'ya pas cette unanimité
et que donc c'est compliqué de faire
pression sur les impasses sur les autres
et c'est maintenant site rentes implique
des droits sur le champagne sur des
produits de luxe français
j'ai sort de leurs vins comme sur le vin
j'espère que la solidarité européenne la
existera mais aujourd'hui notre meilleur
moyen finalement de ne pas céder à
tringles c'est qu'il n'y ait pas en face
de lui de lune de l'unanimité
merci philippe béchade avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes analyste
finances et rédacteur en chef de la
bourse au quotidien merci